good day and welcome i'm jack van horn from the
university of virginia please allow me to welcome
you to this edition of our 2020 2021 foundations
of biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture is supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of arts
and sciences the school of data science
and through a grant from the national
institutes of general medical sciences
today it is my honor and privilege to welcome
our speaker dr hong-wei dong who is professor
of neurobiology at the university of california in
los angeles dr dong received both his md and his
phd in china after which he became a postdoctoral
fellow in the laboratory of dr larry swanson at
the university of southern california following
his post-doctoral fellowship he was a founding
neuroscientist at the allan brain institute in
seattle washington where he worked to construct
the original allen reference atlas for the
brain of the c-57 black laboratory mouse
this atlas and its revisions have been at the
core of many allen brain atlas research projects
research products papers and other resources
dr dong began his faculty career at ucla
in 2007 in the laboratory of neuroimaging where
he pioneered several white matter fiber tract
tracing methodologies publishing
many papers in prominent journals
in 2013 he and his laboratory relocated across los
angeles to the university of southern california
he's recently returned to ucla's department of
neurobiology to take on a professorship there and
to continue this painstaking work he's sponsored
by several grants from the national institutes
of health's brain initiative and his research
focuses on the multi-scale wiring diagram and
cataloging with cell types in the mouse brain most
notably dr dong is the founder and director of the
mouse connect dome project mouseconnectum.org
which is a valuable resource for understanding
the brain connectivity in the standard laboratory
mouse as noted he has received funding through
the nih brain initiative and at one time was
listed among the top 1 of nih-funded researchers
again the work in his laboratory includes that
painstaking work involved of track tracing studies
of neuronal fiber pathways in the brain of the c57
black laboratory mouse and uses uh computational
methodologies to examine the rich patterns of
neuronal connectivity and to make inferences about
the wiring patterns of the standard laboratory
mouse brain today his lecture is titled um
hold on today his lecture is titled assembling
uh global networks of the mouse brain and
as always we are streaming this lecture live
and for recording via youtube and if you're
watching on youtube thank you for joining us
uh also our specially selected 20 20 20 2021
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants are encouraged to submit
any questions for dr dong via the chat feature
in their zoom sessions i will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf in the
last 10 minutes or so of dr dong's lecture
and with that welcome hong-wei we are very
very excited to hear your lecture today
okay uh first i want to send jack uh you
invite me to give this talk and talk about our
work in the last 10 years and that was a very
nice introduction thank you very much jack
all right uh so my laboratory uh in the last 10
years as what jack mentioned uh we're trying to
map the brain maps and neural circuitry and
this project is part of the brain initiative
and for the one major uh topic for the brain
initiative uh is try to understand how the
different many neurons it's six billion neurons
that's inhuman but it's a in the mouse brain about
a hundred million neurons how these different
neurons they connect to each other uh form the
neural networks conduct the uh different behavior
functions and how the different disease uh what's
happening when the certainty gets disrupted
and how that will relate to different disease
models and obviously this is not the easy task in
the mammalian brain from mouse to human there are
about 800 to 1000 different brain structures
our mission is trying to understand how these
different brain structures they are connected with
each other individually at regional level and also
eventually will be at a single neuron resolution
so obviously the brain is organized at a
as a highly organized higher hierarchic networks
so obvious from the first is the brain and the
brain itself can be subdivide several major
subdivisions cerebral hemisphere cerebellum
lower brain stem and each one of them in
turn can be subdivide multiple structures
and eventually go to the individual brain
structures and then subdivisions and then
uh individual neurons that is uh the automated
resolutions look at the individual neuron
resolution so when we map the brain we can
follow obviously the different principles
one principle is just like our human body you
look at it topographically what's happening in
the head four limbs the lower limbs uh and in the
brain basically you can look at the the cortex
uh basal ganglia asylums have asylum that is one
way to look at topographically and another way is
follow their system level just like in the human
body at the beginnings you can look at the for
example circulation system that you got the veins
uh um artery and a heart and they organize as a
network or muscle system so in the brain also the
same thing uh this uh diagram that is from a cacao
original joints and here he showed his dorsal
root ganglia cells sends the process to the skin
and receives this sensory information getting to
the spinal cord and then this information goes up
to the silence then go to the cortex from cortex
can send the uh projections directly to the spinal
cord and innovate motor neurons and that innovates
the muscle so basically that is across multiple
stations that is a whole system so that is a one
level we can understand how these different brain
structures they organized as networks so again i
show you this another house original joints you
can see beautifully showed in the retina has
multiple different cell types each individual
neurons they have dendrites receive the inputs
and axon go to the next uh target and here's a
tecton and sends the projection to here and the
neurons here also receive the impulse go to the
uh its own target so it's from one station to
another one so overall in the last several decades
uh so we internal neuroscience um is in particular
for anatomy what we're trying to understand always
the three major things one is the different cell
types in the individual regions and in terms of
their circuitries the wines local circuitries how
the locally uh individual neurons they affect with
each other especially for local circuitry so
we talk about the interneurons they affect the
surrounding neurons and for long-range projections
we really look at their extrinsic connections so
if we look at the diagram like one individual
regions they send projections to the downstream
and also receive inputs from
upstream as a chin connections
but we should keep it in mind uh is one
individual burning regions obviously you can
uh keep subdividing into the smaller subdivisions
and in the at the regional level we look at that
we use classical treasures so we can look at the
regional per connection the input output but at
the final resolution each individual regions also
contains multiple different brings multiple cell
types and this individu this individual cell
types their connections can be really different
and uh eventually where we go to the single
neural resolution so another uh major thing what
as a neuroscientist we map the neural circuitry is
we're not only producing the data just that is one
major thing i want to emphasize as this is a brain
initiative connectome so our mission is not only
just producing large amount of data but really
even more important thing also is to understand
uh this data convert this uh connectivity
data imaging data into the usable knowledge
just like a cacao originally he got this beautiful
joints here but you notice all these little arrows
here to show you how the different part of the
structures they connect with each other uh this
obvious is a classical synaptic circuitry from
internal cortex to dental gels to c3c1 uh these
circuitries that's our job as a neuroscientist
neuroanatomy so we're not only producing data
but also really understand how this data what
that data means and um one important thing
is for each individual nodes in these connections
they can receive the multiple inputs for example
these nodes and two here receives the multiple
inputs receive the convergence inputs but also
they can send a projection downstream we didn't
put here but it's also sent to the multiple inputs
to the multiple target just like on one here has
one target here another target here so which means
like when we look at map the circuitries we
start from individual brain structures as one
functional nodes uh see their inputs see their
output but also we need to understand from some
multiple nodes how these eventually put together
these networks how they interact with each other
so uh overall if we look at the entire brain how
they connect with each other it's almost just like
these pianos piano has a fixed number of keys
but with different combinations they can play
infinitive music piece so our brain the automate
the the basic elements that is motor neurons
but these different combinations they can
conduct different behavior different functions
so the neural circuitry itself that is for how
to organize these different individual neurons
individual brain structures and affords a more
higher and higher level complex cognition emotion
and behavior so overall that is my introduction i
just talked about like hour over all my programs
like uh try to understand the first things
understand how the whole brain constructs
the whole brain wiring diagram and then we try to
understand each individual brain structures there
how many different cell types and then we need
to understand at a single neuron resolution their
input output organization so this mouse connectom
project as jack mentioned we started this purge
project uh about 10 years ago when i was
at ucla that was a start beginning with
together with other institute their connection
uh project and also cold spring harbor has
another brain architecture connectivity project
so this is three major projects to map the mouse
brain miso scale connections um so this is one of
the example images i want to show uh so the our
connectome project we use multiple fluorescent
tracers can label multiple pathways at the same
time so for example the red color fibers bundles
that is come from a secondary motor cortex and
this green color that is from infrared limbic
cortical areas you know at the same time we
also label the neurons um that's the individual
neurons they project back to the cortex so um
so in my talk today what i want um present is
in our last 10 years work we start from this
map the cortex to look at how entire cortical
different critical areas with each other they
form these different cortical cortical networks
and then systematically look at the entire cortex
they project to the striatum and then look at the
from striatum their projections to the downstream
pattern [ __ ] and from here project back to the
asylums and then back to the cortex uh the reason
for that one is because it's an entire cortical
uh basal ganglia islamic circuitry that is one of
the most uh functional motifs in the brain i
involved many functions involved many diseases
so therefore the code copies of ganglions in
human brain you know we know they have the
cute man here's the massive cortex and also
here's the uh globus pallidus and here's the
[ __ ] uh this is in human and in the classical
classic view for corticobysoganglia system is
they form these several parallel major uh major
loops called cortical basal ganglia cellamic loop
and eventually back to the cortex involved
with different functions like a motor
and eye movements and cognition emotion
things so in the last 10 years we did
the systematic uh studies refined this is called
the entire cortical piece of ganglia islamic globe
so firstly we look at the entire cortex it's a
mouse neocortex this work was published in 2014
and the method we used is called double coil
injection which means like in each individual
brain we do the stereotax surgeries make two
injections each injections contains one retrograde
tracers back label their upstream neurons at same
time label their downstream projections uh so
once fluorogold bda actually now we use morse aeb
and another injections we reach a great treasure
that is a color toxin anterior tracer is a phl
so in this case in one brain we can map up four
parallel uh pathways two anterior grid to
retrograde and so here's the examples to show
this uh control lateral side of secondary motor
cortex axons come from injection site and this
retrograde labeling neurons project back to
the injection site here's their samples of the
labeling neurons and here's one example injection
site you can see the axons come from injection
site go to the contralateral side generate axonal
terminals and here's terminals at the same time
the ritual grid neurons also here these neurons
project back to the contralateral side and when
we see this overlapped anterior grid retrograde
we know this region and this region they have
reciprocal connections so for the entire mouse
cortex we use the 300 injection site which means
because remember each injection site we have
a mixed one anterior grid one retrograde so
which means like we have totally 600 pathways
so we selected 240 pathways we generate this
uh connectivity map in the entire cortex use
different colors map their different pathways
so for example like here we showed is all these
entire somatic sensory cortical areas primary
motor secondary motor primary sensory secondary
sensories and totally all these individual somatic
sensory motor areas and then we look at their
pathways and then we find out uh these entire
semantic motor pathways they are organized
as several parallel sub-networks for example
all this green color labeled pathways
that is in the controlled upper limb
movement include the primary motor cortex has
their upper limb domain primary somatosensory
has their upper limb domain and secondary
motor cortex have their upper limb domains
and it's a green blue color that is for
the our official and the red color that is
for more lower limb so basically the total is the
three four to four parallel different different
uh sub networks can show different parts of a
semantic sensory motor cortex functions and also
another major networks we call it media
networks which means includes the visual cortex
auditory cortex and a ritual splinting area
that is received directly input from hub campus
so basically the information from outside
world visual auditory and spatial information
these guys they they share massive connections
with richard's planning area and her singlet
cortex these cortical areas along the midline
of the brain and then they form this high level
uh interconnect networks and then project the
frontal cortex that is orbital frontal cortex
and this network that is really the process the
information from outside world on the other hand
the cortical areas along the lateral edge of the
cortex for example and granular insular cortex in
toronto cortex and temporal association areas
these guys form two parallel uh pathways that
connect with each other also connect to the mid
media prefrontal cortex they process information
from our inner world that is a visceral olfactory
customer and self-awareness this information
so if we put together uh conduct this kind of
network matrix analyze we find the entire cortex
they are organized as about a dozen different sub
networks for example like a four semantic sensory
motor areas two media sub networks and uh two uh
lateral sub networks they are organized as these
functional networks conduct a different behavior
and interesting all of these connections they have
the interactions are run in the frontal area
that i think that is the information can allow
the entire cortex information they flow this
uh intact through this amount these different
sub-networks so overall that is our work for
maps the entire cortical networks so after that
one our next step was we look at how the entire
cortex the interactive is the stratum because
the striatum that is the first station receive
the inputs from the entire cortex and this work
is the to do that we we made the injections
into all the different cortical areas and
then to look at their projection patterns
in the mouse stratum and interestingly we we
saw almost like no identical uh labeling patents
in the striatum for example these injections in
the primary somatosensory cortex their terminal
field men is here you see their terminals
like this pattern but another way the parietal
association areas they show this kind of a band
another injection is in the visual cortex they
show this a vertical band near the lateral
ventricle so basically it's overall the from
individual cortical areas they project to the
stratum they not only show this heterogeneous
their distribution patterns are different but
also even their terminals how they distribute
in the striatum also is really different
so and then we generate this is a detailed map
uh for the axonal terminals from individual
critical areas put them together you can see
their uh distinguished topographic patterns
some critical areas they have more overlap some
is relatively segregate so basically we can see
the hulls from different cortical areas of their
convergence and divergence in different part of
strident and then we can conduct this systematic
uh quantitative analyze for their terminals in
strident so this part i don't have time to go
to the detail but however we just really look
at from each individual cortical areas where
they are really dense terminal core and also
they are diffused terminals around because this
one has a different functional meanings for the
inputs to universe is a different stratum part and
then we look at a topographically how different
part of a stratum their terminals correlate with
a different part of a stratum for example there's
a green color that's a uh metal somatic sensory
motor areas involved uh this uh lower limb trunk
and actually the upper limb artificial part the
projections mainly go to this venture lateral
side of the striatum this part mostly is involved
artificial this artificial upper limb area but the
for lower limb and trunk part they project more
dorsal side of the striatum and this yellow part
receives inputs from this medius of the network's
visual auditory retrosplenium area anterior
cingulate cortex and this pink area receive more
the input from classically we call it olympic
system that is in the granular insular temp in
a uh in toronto cortex project of these areas
and if we look at even more detail conduct a
more detailed network analyze we really look
at the entire stratum we can subdivide them
into the about 30 different functional domains
each of these individual functional demands they
receive their special set of the cortical inputs
so for example like here that's again that is the
entire semantic sensory motor area remember they
forms distinctive sub networks so we can see how
these different cyber networks they project to the
uh striatum but they hear interesting things
like their projection to the stratum they form
this upside down the homunculus so basically
it's like a trunk from trunk cortical areas from
primary somatosensory primary motor cortex the
if they are related to trunk functions the their
terminals in the dorsolateral stratum for the oro
facial parts they are more like a ventral lateral
side of the striatum so they have some
part overlap some part of a divergency but
overall is remembered in the cortex part of they
have like a semantic sensory symmetrical motor
the if they are formed sub-networks that control
the trunk or lower limb they project to mostly
overlap terminals in the stratum so if their mouse
regions are projected to the ventral lateral side
so again uh so the uh for the visual auditory
and the median networks the muscle is a project
to this dorsal medial region of the stratum
but the insular part and also in toronto
cortex the project is the ventral lateral side
of striatum and again this one that is really
highly correlated with the cortical networks
if the cortical areas in the cortex part they
heavily connect to each other the project tended
to has like more overlap in the same same domains
in the uh strident and here's some really nice
relatively segregated terminals in the stratum
so based on overall this entire cortical there are
terminals in the striatum this this is the maximum
projections of the axon terminal from more than
80 different cortical areas there are terminals
in the stratum based on this pattern we can see
this stratum clearly this functional related
means for example this dorsal media domain here
receive convergent inputs from the visual cortex
and the insurance cortex which means this part
of a stratum properly involves the integration
of the visual visual spatial information and this
part that is for trunk this part of our artificial
and this part that is for visceral motor uh input
from the cortex and this kind of a functional map
across the entire stride and more rostral or more
coda but they have the different special ways
for example in the relatively more cauter part
of striatum they have segregations relatively
dorsal part you got like i have neck trunk
movements uh all these cortical areas projected
here but the lymph parts they projected here
and here's more like for our official part and
the more really color part of stratum is involved
primarily inputs from the visual auditory inputs
but this part of striatum actually
people knows very little about it
all right after we look at the entire cortical
cortical networks look at it there is entire
cortex project with the stratum and next step is
we look at how from the different these functional
uh domains identity identify function domains of
the stratum project it's downstream structure that
is globus paradise and uh substitution i graph
and then from there how the projected asylums
and then go back to cortex so the question really
is if we see the cortex uh topographic projection
to the striatum and the now we identify all
these clear subdivisions of the stratum what
is their major how their these patterns go
to the next step the paradigm and the niagara
so this part of work still not published but we
already saw very clear very interesting patterns
for example this is from stratum their projection
to the globus paradise to show all these
really clearly segregate demands and this
is from the major divisions intermediate
uh stratum rostral cord or stratum this
shows its patterns but also if we see the
community levels the dorsal lateral ventrome
lateral dorsal medial ventral medial also sees
relative separate patterns but interestingly is
if we go to really find domains in the striatum
they also show the clear pattern in the paradigm
as the globus pallidus these patterns which means
the cortex inputs to the stratum they're
relatively separated and then they can
also maintain these relatively segregate uh
projection patterns in the paradigm so accordingly
i showed these functional demands and then we can
try to find the correlated demands in the paradigm
so we divided the paradigm into the uh about 40
different domains uh this is just like the legos
the piece and each demand they receive specific
inputs from different part of a stratum
and also we look at how from the different stratum
demand they project to the uh substantial niagara
so remember like this individual stratum
domains they receive very specific inputs from
individual areas and but i showed here that
is more like a several demands in the venture
media demands of the striatum to look at
each individual demand they project to this
uh different part of a niagara and then put
it together we can also see these functional
specialized domains in this in the [ __ ] part and
we mapped these circuitries also at the individual
uh neuron resolution which means like here i
showed several individual neurons to see their
axon individual axons they go to the generated
branches in the paradigm or the terminals in
the niagara so that is a high resolution inputs
high resolution axons and then after we look at
the [ __ ] uh so from the striatum to the [ __
] and then we look at from individual niagara
how they project back to the salons like here i
use the example that is uh uh for the uh called
paravascular nucleus pf uh ceramic nucleus
these guys to receive the same domain
of this pf receive the inputs from cortex but
also receive the core correlated domain from the
stratum from the solution [ __ ] so which means
like if this part of a striatum uh receive the
inputs from the uh the cortex the correlate
cortex and we can find the how the in the syllabus
part there are cortical inputs to this islamic
nucleus and actually receive the convergence input
from the substitution [ __ ] so in this case
you form this kind of an entire cortical basal
ganglia islamic cortex this kind of loop just
like what i showed here the same uh islamic
domains these they project back to these cortical
areas in the same cortical areas projected these
ceramic nucleus uh this one projector striatum but
this part a stratum project is a uh corresponding
demands in the [ __ ] and a [ __ ] project back
to the islamic nucleus and then this guy project
back to the cortex so in this case we can really
really see how this is the entire cortical piece
of ganglion islamic globe they form this kind of
a really interesting uh closed subnetworks and
we also mapped this neurons in the niagara what
is their morphology their individual neurons
how their dendrites extend throughout this niagara
part and also how does their dendrites match with
their inputs from the stratum so overall um
so overall um i don't have time to go to the
really detailed every sub networks but overall
the information here is this so entire cortex
we have uh three major networks large relatively
large networks for example somatic sensory
motor networks they can they are organized as
several parallel networks can show trunk lower
limb upper limb inner mouse outer mouse these
regions and then each individual sub network
they have primary motor cortex primary sensory
secondary motor secondary sensory uh each one of
these sub networks they heavily connect with each
other in the at cortex level and then these guys
in the same sub-networks they generate convergent
inputs to the stratum the same domain it doesn't
mean they're terminals they are completely
overlapped they still show some some interesting
patterns but they project the same domain uh
what we need onstage as this stratum individual
neuron resolution how this individual neuron the
information from different cortical areas they
integrated at individual neural resolution but
that is a future work um and you see like it's
a somatic sensory motor parts they converge
into the different subdomains mostly the
lateral side of striatum that is correlated to
the human putamen part but the media associative
sub networks that is includes anterior cingulate
cortex ritual splenic area parietal association
area orbital frontal cortex they project
to the dorsal medial striatum part and
lateral cortical areas they project
to the venture media strident part but
each individual demands in the strident they
then send the parallel projections to the pattern
at the same time they send interesting convergence
divergence and patterns to the different part of a
uh substrate niagara and remember stridom also
has projections to the pattern paradigm they
have projections to the uh niagara so which means
like if we bring in our classic concept direct
pathways versus the individual indirect cortical
visual ganglia pathways but you know different
uh principles i don't have time to go to the
detail for that uh but eventually when we see
this niagara project back to the asylums use
the paraphrase killer nucleus as examples they
also form these parallel pathways from here
then they project back to the entire cortex
so this work is not completely done yet but i
think like down the road in the next several years
we're going to uh go to even more details to see
each individual for example like at the niagara
part individual [ __ ] neurons how they receive
the convergent input from the striatamia and also
from paradigm and how this you know another really
quick questions how these pathways uh individual
pathways if the past we get disrupted how that
one relate to like a classic disease for example
parkinson's huntington's disease and because
in these different disease models for example
huntington's the the huntington's they show
different symptoms for example at the beginning
stage people have a problem patients have a
problem for for their eye movement and then
they have a problem for swallowing a food that
means they have some problem with artificial motor
parts and eventually it's come to the really lean
problems and they also has cognition like both the
huntington's and parkinson's patients they have
cognitive problems and cognitive problems actually
come before even mortal uh problems so i think
like if we we really mapped all these networks
really clearly and we because we know lots
of functions about the cortex for example uh
media prefrontal cortex that is involved lots of
cognitive functions uh and anterior intercinglic
cortex involved a different function from the
motor cortex and then we if we understand how
the individual cortical areas they go to find
uh demands in the stratum and this stratum how
they affect the downstream projections paradigm
[ __ ] and to the salons that will really help us
eventually understand this really much finer um
resolution just in terms of for the disease model
so uh i just uh i don't have time to go to the uh
really detail but it's like another really major
direction uh so in my lab also it's one major
direction for uh brain initiative in the last
several years and also uh the coming next five
years that is to characterize cell types for
the entire uh mouse brain so which means we look
at this is the one example for the hippocampus
so hubcaps obviously has many different neurons
what we can show here for example is the green
color neurons that is a neuron project to the
anterior ventral islamic nucleus you see these
neurons really complex dendritic arbors
and each dandruff has all these dendritic
spines you know we know this dendritic
spines that is spot to receive the inputs
and it's a pink color neurons
that is a project back to the
ritual splenium areas and all these red color
neurons that's the neuron project back to the
reunion nucleus of silence so does so
that direction really also is we what we
uh we need to characterize catalog neuronal
cell types uh as a single neural resolution
to look at their inputs and also the single
neural output and this work will be uh really
a tremendous work very labor intensive and uh but
is involved many many groups in the country um
all right so overall uh i introduced my program as
like we how to generate this kind of a multi-skill
wiring diagram uh use the code called visual
ganglia islamic this system as an example and
uh to show how we go from the regional
specific level and go to the subdivisions
and eventually need to go to the individual
resolution and also i briefly mentioned uh the
another major direction is to catalog cell types
in the brain so uh for this connectome project
obviously that is has been ongoing for in the
last 10 years and people have used different
technologies try to understand this connectome
at a different resolution in the neural imaging
field obviously we have lots of like a human
uh micro uh mri dti at this resolution in the
mouse world we use this kind of a classic tracers
use virus tracers to label the neural pathways
and then in the electron microscopy resolution
that is go to really synaptic synaptic resolution
so eventually what we really want is to integrate
this multi-skill resolution connectome to help us
to really understand how the brain organized at
the different levels eventually will be needed
at the single neural resolution so when i work
on this project really one really good example
uh i want to put here is to show this kind of a
story it's a blind man with elephant you see like
the different the little mans they touch one body
of the elephant and then report okay the elephant
this guy report elephant just like a wall and
this guy report the elephant just like a rope um
so this kind of uh approach really just like you
know we we scientists we as a scientist many times
many years what we are trying to do is because we
use special technology we focus on different brain
regions and we really focus on one region and
then we generate our hypothesis for example if
we really work on part of our brain and we collect
this information we generate a hypothesis and then
we just use this hypothesis to demonstrate okay
my hop house is right uh i think the elephant
is just like a wall you know so so it's it's
a scientific evidence but on the other hand
uh we need have a global view so hopefully
the connection this project eventually
we can integrate the information from all
different modalities different disciplines
uh so and then can give us a big picture what
the elephant is um so that is uh really to bring
up into this data science so why the data
science really important really is not only
just regenerate data but eventually we need to
understand this data you know what that data means
okay um i can stop here for my talk and so
i uh this is my lab and obviously my work is
involved not only just for generated data but
also involved lots of computational parts i didn't
talk elaborate here but it really just
that is a contribution great contributions
from my lab over years and especially
for uh hurry she made a tremendous
contribution for the organized uh the project
to help help the project really ongoing
and uh nick uh brian involves the major
papers here and in a woman that is
he is our informatics group leader in the movie
you developed a lot of great informatics um
tools and also the rest of the lab uh did all the
great contributions and also my collaborators in
my different brain initiative uh project and
i really appreciate the support from brain
initiative and uh mh okay so i can stop here and
take some questions and thank you very much for
your attention oh hong-wei thank you so much that
is just such a tour to force amount of work and
uh just a lot of work by a lot of really great
people too who many of whom i happen to know
personally and so it's a it's so nice to see
it all come together one of the things which
is always kind of uh interesting to think about
is i as i understand uh your choice you chose the
to to look at the c57 black mouse because it's
the most ubiquitous laboratory animal in the
world and that understanding the brain of that
example species would be really important for
um for others you know just terms of its
ubiquity their uh the genetic homogeneity of it
um it was made a really great model
but i'm curious because it has been so
studied and has been so looked at did you what is
the really the thing that really got you excited
as the new discovery of looking at the brain of
this particular animal yeah so we pick up this
mice it's not because one reason is
really just because it's a practical and
we study the neural circuitry eventually to try
to understand their function so for the c57 black
that is the most popular models for the genetics
so there are so many genetic disease models use
this user mouse and uh molecular people they
they use this one you know all the genomic
people they you also use mouse brain and also
in terms of size in terms of your circuitry
because it's much smaller it's easier to you
look at the entire mouse brain i don't have
the time talk today but like uh recent years
we started using the light sheet microscopy
do the brain clearing and then to look
at internal mouse connection patterns
so the mouse brain is relatively smaller so
give you the um opportunity to map the entire
brain rather in comparison with the right and
monkey's brain they are much bigger and then
that will be involved even more uh ones labor
and other things really date size and also the
mouse really the most important things because we
can direct the core a little bit use the later on
for people you use the genetic model so we when we
look at the uh circuitries in the wide type mice
and we can use this the same circuitry people can
understand in the disease models how that happened
that's being said but recent years for the brain
initiative start to really think about it like
i use the monkeys because for us automate
goal is really understanding human brains
so the primates for example mom's side
that is a really good model uh to uh
for us the next step after we understand the
mouse to see the in the user mode in your
mom's side to look at uh in the primates what's
the circuitry is common in the mouse brain and
what is the difference and that mom side
can be as an intermediate station for us to
really understand the human brain but obviously
eventually we need to see in the human brain how
the connectivity compare with mouse brain
us many of these circuitries we learn from
mouse can be applied in the human for example this
uh cortical striatal projection that i just showed
my thinking is we find the really finer
subdivisions in the mouse striatum functional
demands the same thing can be applied directly
in the human brain and obviously still a lot
of work needed to be done for a human brain and
that is that we're waiting for some new exciting
technologies coming out in the next several years
do you plan to do any work with um kind of disease
model mice i mean it sounds like you alluded to
that are there any specific diseases that uh you
would want to try to uh to look for look at the
connectivity of in mouse models yes we have been
trying to look at the uh this connectivity in the
huntington's disease uh and also at mice um but
to go to the disease model part and that's also
it's really uh it's not the easy task so we need
to devote our time specifically to work on
this model you know but that is definitely
that is the direction we're going so we we at
this moment we really tours to think about is
really the huntington's and also 80 and the
property also parkinson's three major models
that's cool um here's a question from one of our
uh uh participants um what about parafasicular
projections to the striatum do they largely
overlap with the inputs from cortical regions
they connect to and could this redundancy be a
mechanism behind why locomotor control and many
aspects of learning are preserved in decorticated
mice you have any thoughts on that uh yes so
paravascular it turns out that actually it's a
very interesting uh very interesting structures
i'm just like so happy at the beginning stage we
didn't in fact it's so complicated and so when
we look at our uh projections connections
actually it's the reciprocal connections
paraphrasical of these cortex we find the para
vascular nucleus can be subdivided into this
multiple domains and these multiple demands
they are very highly topographically arranged
for example the paravesticular uh the lateral part
para vesicula more dorsal part that is the more uh
heavily reciprocal connections with the cortex
related to control the trunk part uh relatively
more vengeful in as like an intermediate middle
level that is for the upper limb and eventual
lateral side of paravascular nucleus that is for
the controlled artificial part but like more media
site like a dorsal and a ventral side that is a
parafasicular nucleus release heavily involved
is a classic limbic cortical areas for example
in from limbic cortical areas they you know they
release in the media also lateral cytoparaphysical
nucleus and we interestingly we find is
when we map these cortical striatal pathways
and these pathways from niagara different
domains the project paraphysical nucleus really
match just like you might talk i mentioned is
the same functional loop actually all preserved
from cortex to striatum to the [ __ ] then to
paraphysical nucleus then back to the cortex
so it's thinking like we for the paraphrasic
letter we identified the six major domains that
is uh six parallel sub-networks came back to
the cortex did i answer your question right i i i
think that is a great answer uh for that question
so thank you i hope that our our uh participant
was satisfied um one thing that you mentioned is
the the notion of looking at mapping the cells in
the mouse brain and i'm thinking of things like um
broad men's regions for example in the human brain
which are so widely noted um but i also know that
broadman did some work in his cytoarchitectonic
corpus um in a number of other species i believe
including the mouse i'm curious whether or not
you find any sort of mappings that would link
cytoarchitectonics with some of the conictomics
you're seeing and that have overlap between these
projection areas and the regions that you're
identifying does there seem to be some sort of
cell type uh pattern as well that superimposes
itself upon this conictomic pattern yeah so
yeah another project i didn't talk about
today here that is a recent project um is
a really collaborative project is among more
than 16 different institutes cross country
from this brain initiative cell sense network i'm
the organizer for the anatomy part so in this part
we look at the cell types in the primary
motor cortex so basically so we define is
the primary motor cortex anatomically and
especially we focus on the uh primary motor cortex
upper limb area so we look at the different
cell types in this primary motor cortex they
project to the different cell types for
example layer two three neurons layer uh
four eventually we identified the primary motor
cortex actually also has a very thin layer layer
four uh and the layer five neurons they project to
the different part of brain so for example let's
see uh in the human you got like a really big
cortical spinal projection neurons in the primary
motor cortex in the mouse brain actually yeah that
is basically the same cell types also has this
big neurons project to the spinal cord and
we use the tracers to label these neurons
injecting to the cervical spinal cord back labels
big neurons in the cortex we know these guys
where exactly where they're located and where
they project you so we basically identify these
neurons cortical spinal projection
neurons use a different anatomical uh
tracer method region specifically and also the use
single neuron we can see single neurons projected
to the downstream medulla different parts and
then see their brains but at the same time also
brain initiative sponsored other groups they look
at the individual neurons what is their molecular
uh profiles you know so what is the molecular
identities so this information can be used
actually in the other groups in the brain needs to
sponsor groups already compare the same cell types
try to look at uh cross difference between mouse
monkeys and humans what is their molecular uh
ident molecular profiles whether you can
find the same moleculars or different
uh and then compare their cell types so eventually
in the down syndrome sex in the next several years
this information we will you will get we will get
a really massive amount of data try to compare the
different cell types across human and mouse brain
you know also primates brain well this is leads
me into my next question is uh there's clearly an
enormous amount of data science which is required
to deal with this massive amount of individual
cellular data how they're all connected what
subsystems and sub-networks exist in these large
data sets what do you see as some of the things
that data science can contribute to and what do
you see as kind of attributes that data scientists
you know might have if they're going to come
into this field and help analyze this rich
amount of neural information yeah so actually
the data science that'll become really key
uh for downgrade and for producing data is only
the first step so over the last several years
like my lab that is a student's academic labs
a relatively small academic lab but we already
produced huge amount of connectivity data and we
can obviously we are trying our best to to write
papers try to understand how different regions
they form these networks but still though we
still have tons tons data just in our computer
uh we haven't got time to really analyze that
one and alan institute obviously that is a big
institute they produce tons tons of data artists
in there as they release in their website but
the key question still is how we can understand
this data so so that one just really come to the
uh the data science part we need to develop a more
uh powerful tools um to really uh to analyzing
data to especially perform the integrative analyze
joint data analyze so that is a part of this
of brain initiative cell sensor networks and
that's a i'm involved this program that's a brain
initiative sponsored so for this program they ask
every lab in this program producing the data
and then we submit this data to pittsburgh
supercomputer center that is as a data center
for the brain initiative and brain initiative is
going to release this data make it available to an
entire community that is the first step makes this
data openly available to the entire community
and then this offers the data available second
approach second step actually involved all of us
our we have the brain initiative grants but also
actually involved should be like for the entire
community try to really understand this in your
circuitry data and a single neuron iron sequence
data and some spatial transcription data how to
put this data together i try to understand um what
this data means especially uh for understanding
neural cell types for the cell types that
is uh we define the cell types is a not
only we shouldn't define cell types based on one
criteria based on their connection or based on
their uh our singular our sequence data instead
we should based on their integrity features for
example these cell types what is their um first
is the anatomy location where they're located
they're in the primary motor cortex or the
primary sensory cortex and also their connections
their physiology properties what is their firing
patterns and what is their molecular identities uh
eventually i'm saying what is their uh function
what's this cell type involved which behavior
control which behavior what function so basically
when all of this really require the data science
to data science to uh that is involved
importantly many different things
include the data visualization well thank you
hong-wei i really appreciate you sharing your
amazing work with us today uh if it is any
indication of the just a massive amount of
work that's ahead of us uh especially uh where
data sciences is related um we're going to have
a a lot of work to do but it's very exciting
work so thank you so much for sharing your
uh your work with us today um i want to thank
everybody who's uh part of our uh biomedical
data science innovation lab program and i want to
thank everybody out on youtube for uh taking part
in our activity today and throughout this year
we're going to be taking a bit of a break over
the holidays so we want to wish you a very
happy holidays and just let you know that uh
we'll be beginning again on january 8th
again 9 a.m pacific and 12 p.m eastern
with our biomedical data science seminar series
and so with that thank you again hong-wei
thank you again everybody have a
happy holidays and a safe new year
and uh we'll see you on january 8th thank you
again thank you very much jack thanks to everyone